cardi b is literally making a dream come
true for kyle penn oh yes honey the
rapper has seemingly agreed to officiate
carl's upcoming wedding following a
heartwarming twitter convo here's how it
all came together you know josh and i
have been together for 11 years we had
our 11th anniversary in october kyle
announced his engagement to long-time
partner josh earlier this week marking
the first time he's spoken out publicly
about his love life cheerio
i've been listening
soon after sharing the happy news carl
took to twitter and spoke a star-studded
fantasy into existence he wrote cardi b
was on my flight to la i fell asleep and
i had a dream that she officiated our
wedding on the plane and the three of us
walked out of lax holding hands
okay kyle what other visions from the
future can you bring us because this
might be happening i just want like
everything to be successful cardi b
replied to carl's tweet writing first
why didn't you say hi
second i'm licensed to do that so
let me know yup and fans of her facebook
messenger series katie tries knew this
was no joke you guys are probably
wondering why i'm here
i'm gonna get these two beautiful ladies
married on a recent episode cardi became
ordained and officiated a wedding for
this happy couple by the power vested in
me by the state of california and my
online course i now pronounce you wife
and wife
so as you can imagine kyle was ecstatic
about cardi's proposal we can't wait to
do it he wrote back you're the best was
gonna say hi but didn't want to be
disrespectful your do not disturb light
was on but holy sh let's do it we're
down if you're down then cardi seemingly
sealed the deal by writing i'm down i'll
get my suit and kyle should maybe get
ready for a surprise wedding twist
because look at what she had in store
for the couple on cardi tries
raven
yep she surprised these brides with
special guest raven simone who served as
a ring bearer for the ceremony i mean
who gets to say that cardi b officiated
their wedding brandy and shannon do and
raven somewhere
you're right i was there
i thought it was interesting how it
presented itself in the book it was
fairly a matter of fact
in an interview this week with cbs
sunday morning kyle opened up about his
new memoir you can't be serious and
sharing details about his relationship
so for me and writing about it i think
the the the tricky thing was you're
right it's it's very matter of fact in
our lives and
when you're the son of indian immigrants
who says that you want to be an actor
the chaos that that creates in your
family and your community will trump
anything else always and with the career
that spans both hollywood and the white
house karl shared his excitement for all
things yet to come i
really feel incredibly blessed when i
have the chance to be part of a project
that i'm really passionate about the
magic to this that i i hope never gets
old
you